Drake walks the 2017 NBA awards red
carpet with a redh hot date only
one the rapper stepped out on Monday
night in New York City to host the event
which honors the best of the best in
basketball with NBC sports reporter
rosling gold on Woody by his side the
two posed it up for some adorable photos
as Drake wrapped his arm around her
later he posted this pick to Instagram
writing my stunning date for the evening
while it's unclear if Drake and RZ are
an item we do know that the hip-hop
heavyweight started crushing on her
almost 2 years ago in 2015 the
30-year-old shared this snapshot with RZ
on Instagram after his hometown team the
Toronto Raptors lost to the Golden State
Warriors he captioned the pick quote
when the post game makes you forget
about what happened during the actual
[Music]
game